well you've not only got Ireland in your
Bloods your descendants we've also got
tech in your blood you were on the board
of ebay what is the future business
model of the auto industry look like to
you when tech is involved it's a be very
different than today's model because the
whole world of city driving is changing
and it's going to change to something
quite unrecognizable today so whether
it's you know the way you own a car or
don't own one I mean you know access to
a vehicle the autonomous driving
connected vehicles all these things are
going to come into being and it's going
to change our business model and it's
going to change the way people use
vehicles in cities so what's the value
then is if the if you can no longer
exponentially sell more and more cars as
people share them where then is the
value of the 40 so the value will come
in different streams and and so if you
think of transportation as a service you
know the traditional model was you had
hardware and you sold that hardware and
the major profit from that that won't
disappear in fact we'll be living in
both worlds for some time but the world
of city driving is going to change
dramatically and there will be lots of
different revenue streams and we have
prop way of experiments going all around
the world trying different things
whether it's you know fractional
ownership whether it's using a car to
actually do social good and you know
lots of things like that and we don't
precisely know where all these revenue
streams are but one thing we do know is
it will change and change incredibly
rapidly and we want to participate in
that have you got to control the data to
a certain extent what do you think about
the apples the Google's of this world
coming into the auto industry and
disrupting it I think it's great I think
they're bringing great energy and really
interesting new ideas to the industry
and so you know you think of our
industry we've had no revolutions for a
hundred years or more and now we're at
this you know at the doorstep I believe
of of several revolutions all happening
at once
technology and also a people use that
technology and use their cars so you
know I think it's wonderful that we have
all these new players coming in
including startups coming in we have a
lot of young disruptors coming into our
industry and we as a company just need
to remain curious open-minded and
recognizing that a lot of people are
doing very interesting things that we
could potentially partner with you talk
about a revolution you talk about
technology as well as it springs to mind
at the moment software being used
perhaps not always for a force for good
but you know diesel gate Volkswagen
scandal at the moment how are you
interpreting that how is that changing
and revolutionising your industry at the
moment well first of all I don't really
don't to comment on another company but
you know I think you know a lot of it
comes down to your own culture the
culture we have as a company is
something that I work very hard at
maintaining and as do all our employees
the one of openness one of
accountability and one of dealing with
reality and so if you uncover a problem
you deal with it and you deal with it
openly and transparently that's the way
I you know I expect the for culture not
break and whether it's software or
anything else that we are going to you
know there are always issues facing
companies governments in individual
human beings and so you need guideposts
though every and every time to help you
along the way and so anyway that so I
you know in some ways this new world of
software that we ran into if we keep
that in mind I think we'll be fine so
which sort of tech startups are you
looking at to involve within your
business in a transparent manner and
which areas are you looking to disrupt
first is it about collecting data is it
about parking is it about which areas
you victus happening or concurrently and
that's what's so cool is that you know
you've got all these buckets you've got
you know Donna me you've got connected
vehicles you've got parking you've got
ways of ownership that's changing or
accessing vehicles and it's all
happening now is it won't happen
sequentially and so and so we're working
across and I think the company that can
stitch all this together in a way that
makes the customers life easier and I
think that's really important because we
can all fall in love for technology for
its own sake and forget the for a moment
that this is all about making people's
lives individuals in a society's life
better and easier and so one thing we
don't want to do is introduce a whole
suite of technologies in a way that the
customer says I don't understand this
and I can't deal with this so it's up to
us and we also have to understand we
have a wide range of people that are
tech-savvy or not that are out there and
we have to make all this available to
every one of them and so that that will
be I think an art and a science for us
going forward when it take partnerships
will you who will win out the auto
companies or the tech companies or do
you have to work together we have to
work together I mean we have tremendous
domain knowledge in a lot of areas
including the integration of software
into a vehicle and that's critical but
they bring you know big tech companies
and young tech companies they bring a
lot of really interesting aspects and we
have to understand that we can't do it
all ourselves and shouldn't do it all
ourselves it's a different world